well how does it feel to be wealthy now
after after grinding after this for so
long it's better than before it is it is
definitely not
[Music]
Doug I want to give you an intro because
I've been a fan of yours forever and I
in 2019 or 2020 when our podcast was
much smaller I told Sean about you I go
this guy Doug is very fascinating I
think he should launch like some type of
like car website I'm not sure then you
did and then we talked about it and I'm
like I'm pretty sure this is going to be
huge and so I want to take a little bit
I want to take like one percent you know
I helped you succeed I get a little bit
of credit because I I picked you you're
my you're my horse and I bet you know
there's something real I'm sure we'll
discuss this but there's something real
about that like I tell all my friends
now in this space like you need to start
businesses like this will not last
forever you need to start businesses and
I think smart people who learn the
business World kind of realize that and
you were my you are my guy and so for
the audience who don't know
um so Doug tomorrow has a uh it started
as a you're just a YouTuber I guess I
mean you're originally a journalist for
a bunch of different websites where you
would write these funny quirky blogs
then you parlayed that into a YouTube
channel that I think now has like four
million subscribers but the reason why
you're huge and lovable is for a few
different reasons one
you dress really funny so like you'll
wear like khaki shorts like from the
early 2000s with like a red Polo shirt
and then your white undershirt will be
longer than the sleeves of your polo
shirt so it's like hanging out on the
sleeves and like you just dressed like
horribly even though your videos each
get like two or three million views like
you're on uh Jay Leno's um pod uh or
you're on Jay Leno's YouTube like a few
days ago and you're wearing Saucony like
running shoes I'm like what are you
doing dude well Jimmy Jane is not like
Jay's dressing up you know so I I feel
like I I there's not a high bar there
anyway you're just like you're very
likable because of the way you dress
you're very funny you're very um quirky
because that's one of your things you
talk about the quirks of its cars you're
very quirky you're very relatable and so
you've grown this YouTube channel to
like four million subscribers you
launched this company called cars and
bids which is like almost like eBay but
for different types of cars cars
enthusiasts so cars from the 80s 90s and
early 2000s and then recently you sold
the majority of the business the
churning group for around 40 million
dollars I believe when it was only like
two or three years old
um yeah I've bought cars from the
website so anyway I'm a big fan well
thank you I appreciate that thank you
for having me I am I just listened to so
I just bought a car a couple months ago
three three four months ago and uh
it was your YouTube video that put me
over the edge so I bought a Cadillac I
bought an Escalade and I was looking for
a review your review has 1.7 million
views I was like okay this got to be the
best one uh like Sam said uh I was
surprised because I I'm not a car guy at
all uh and also I had never seen your
stuff I had only heard Sam talk about
you on the podcast so I actually didn't
put two two together that oh that's the
same guy that Sam's been talking about
every time I watched the video and I was
like I don't know why I trust this guy
uh what's the uh what's the key to uh to
being the sort of likable trustworthy
guy is that just who you are did you did
you play anything up in your YouTube
videos is there is there any strategy
here or is it all just uh that's just
who you were no that's a good question
and it the answer is there is remarkably
little strategy
um I just it in fact if you go and watch
the videos from before I had a lot of
subscribers they're pretty much the same
so it's not like you know it's not like
I knew what the hell I was doing when I
had 200 000 subscribers it's not like I
knew where this was gonna go
um but I really think I think one of the
reasons though that I kind of did it
this way is that uh a lot of people come
to me and they're like I'm gonna make
the best car videos with 4K drones and
high quality Sound and Music and all
this stuff and I just wanted to like
kind of show people like you actually
can do this as long as the content is
good you can just do this like you can
just do it in your garage you're just
using an iPhone right basically the
shots where I'm like in them there's a
it's a cam it's a Sony 4K camcorder
which isn't cheap but it's also not like
a crazy camera and then an iPhone is
yeah half the video is done
and like you're editing if I remember
correctly up until recently like until
the startup cars and bids you're editing
them and like they're not like
good editing but in a way that makes it
awesome like you know what I mean like
it's a very it's it's really funny it's
it's it's quirky yeah it's simple my
goal was just always to like overload
people with info
and like cool stuff about the cars and
they could decide if they decided that
hey this this quality is not good enough
then they could go find somebody else
but like I always thought that I had the
most info like the most like it like
that when you bought that Escalade like
seeing how all that stuff works how it's
how it's going to fit together sitting
inside it so many other people focus so
much on like Driving Experience there
they do 45 40 like like 20 minute video
and and 18 of the minutes are oh but
here's how it goes through the corners
and I was just like you know like let's
show people the little ins and outs of
the car they are actually gonna buy and
I think that that's like proved to be
quite useful and you also have this
thing at the end I don't know if you saw
this Sean but like I watch every every
single one of his videos and he has this
thing at the end called the Doug score
and if and you kind of like
by the way it seems like I'm like
insulting you constantly but in reality
I've been like love with you but yeah
it's just I don't I get what you're
saying like yeah the the quality was
never the gold the gold was always like
the quality of content you know well
what I'm saying with you you have this
thing called the Doug score which like I
base my buying decisions off of like
I've bought a bunch of cars probably
three or four cars off your like you've
driven you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars of value like to whoever I
bought my car from and you have this
thing called the Doug score at the end
of every video and I went and Googled
and tried to find it and you could
barely find it it's like on a Google
sheet and you have to click file make a
copy so I could sort it because I'm
trying to sort it I'm like
you know what I mean I'm like I want
because you have two categories you have
the weekend category which is uh you
know like a dad who wants to have fun
it's like McLarens and [__] like that
and then you have
um a family or a daily category which is
just like what's good for daily whatever
and some days I'm like you know maybe
I'm in the mood to buy like a a fast car
like let's go let's sort by speed in the
category uh right
um weekend yeah and but I gotta like go
to Excel and I've got to like do like a
like a like a like a row freeze like
it's so complicated why don't you make
this more like robust it's a really this
database could be a business in itself I
know I agree I should do more with it to
be fair the Doug score came out in like
mid 17 and for the first two years it
wasn't really all that valuable because
I didn't really have that many cars in
it and so like late 19 it starts to
become pretty valuable and now there's
got to be like a thousand data points in
there but what happened was I launched
cars and bids I just priorities had to
kind of take shape and yeah I probably
should do more with that because I think
it's valuable also and I think the
really valuable thing would be able to
be to sort by like type of car like if
you want a fast wagon put up all the
fast wagons and then you can just have
that but that's something that that you
could do at home I've decided I've
decided I'm going to just do the videos
inspect I'm a big fan of specialization
and so I decided I'm gonna do the videos
and we're gonna let other people and
sometimes people email me they're like I
just did this great Dana project with
all the dub scored data here it is and I
look at it and it's really cool and it's
like I should be doing that but I'm not
at what point did you uh so the the show
I mean your channel has it been growing
very steadily and was it making enough
income to live off of throughout uh his
existence yeah so I launched the channel
late 13
um but the really big kind of turning
point for the channel was in late 16 I
flipped to two videos a week
um and I don't know that necessarily
that is the Turning Point anymore for a
YouTube channel but in 16 it had a big
effect and
um and almost right away after doing
that yes it became enough money to
listen that I I did that I made that
switch in August of 16 and in December
of 16 I made 20 grand and I was like oh
my God like this is a thing I didn't
know what I didn't know was
Christmas the ad revenue is way higher
at Christmas time and so in January I
made like eight grand and I was like oh
well I guess maybe this isn't a thing I
kind of know what's going on but that
was one of the things I learned
throughout and so yeah like pretty
quickly it it kind of grew at that point
to become something I could live off and
so when you were made that switch you're
like all right I'm gonna start doing two
videos a week is it because you had
heard of the algorithm likes that or you
just happened to do it and saw a bump
what was the what was the reason because
I always wonder with people who get
started with content
um like in retrospect in hindsight it
always makes sense it's like oh of
course people are gonna want to see a
car before they kind of buy it or just
like sit from the comfort of their home
like get to see a review of a car if
that makes sense uh YouTube's the
biggest video platform so whoever does
it on YouTube is gonna benefit there's
gonna be lots of search volume so
they'll probably get views just by
assert by the search of the name of the
car and um right yeah that video is
probably gonna charge a premium or be
worth a premium or maybe make money an
affiliate or something I don't know
exactly what it is but I can see how to
make money it all makes sense at
hindsight at the time in 2013 when you
start doing this did you think there's a
business here and how did you get those
initial views how did you get the
initial momentum was it because of your
following as a writer or was it separate
yeah that's exactly what happened and I
actually got really lucky you know I I
never ever tell people to like work for
um like promotional value like a lot of
times businesses will be like oh instead
of paying you in money I'll pay you in
you know like exposure and I think
that's BS but it actually worked for me
I I wrote for Jalopnik which at the time
was a Gawker blog and was an incredibly
popular one it was the most popular car
blog on the Internet by far and um I
started inserting my videos into those
articles and that drove the Articles
drove people to the videos which then
started to put me in the algorithm which
then started to get me subscribers and
Joel I think was paying me I sort of got
25 an article which was not real money
but like the value was in the number of
people coming over to my YouTube I
didn't know that at the time but in the
years in the later years as as 2013
became 2015 it became clear to me like I
think I'm actually a YouTuber and not a
writer anymore like I think this is a
reality now and so when I decided to
move to two a week what happened was I
left jalopic start a blog with
AutoTrader with Cox Automotive at
AutoTrader and in order to promote that
blog I decided I would be shooting more
videos and within eight weeks I was I
was the video content was suddenly
earning getting way more views and way
more Revenue than the than the writing
content and thankfully the video channel
was your own right the video channel was
your own even though these were guest
blogs on other people's platforms yeah
the agreement with AutoTrader was that I
would uh you know promote on my YouTube
channel these this blog that we had
started
and so I didn't realize that you've been
doing this since 2013. I thought that
I'd was like an OG by like watching
since like 17
um like so I mean you've been grinding
at this first yeah but you pretty much
are because initially I I made videos
with my my own cars and those just never
got as much traction and what the big
switch in 17 was I switched to doing
reviews of cars and suddenly it was a
lot less war because I didn't have to
buy cars and then take on that personal
Financial Risk I would just like show up
at a dude's house film his car and then
peace out and that was a video and there
was like no that didn't cost me anything
except like the gas to get there and so
that was that was a big change it also
allowed me to do more videos because you
can just do more videos that way as
opposed to your own cars you have to
kind of think up a new topic every week
which isn't always easy and so in 17 I
think that's when things really started
to like really take off when I started
to do like car reviews and especially
new car reviews that's what I realized
like okay that's where the money is is
and that's where the audience is but you
make jokes sometimes where you're like
um like for example I watched your def I
I'm I'm thinking about buying a Defender
a new one and I like watched your video
on it and you might make little jokes
you're like one day what I'm able to
afford blank I'll get it and I'm like
seeing your videos I'm like man I think
you could I bet you're making like you
know at least low digit Millions per
year without cars and bids I have to
imagine this was significantly more
lucrative than you like the vibe that
you would joke about sort of but on the
videos but the thing that's I think
important for people to understand
there's there's two components number
one is you never know when it's gonna
end and so like I yeah I was making a
lot of money but
you never know when suddenly a
competitor shows up and it can happen in
a couple of months and suddenly you're
now third fourth fifth in Search and
things are slowing down and so you never
really know like what that day is and so
unlike maybe an attorney or a doctor
where you have these jobs you make a lot
of money less than I was but you have a
lot more job security over long term for
me it was like yeah I have a lot of
money but I saved so much of it because
I was always just terrified that you
know I never knew exactly what was gonna
what was gonna happen What amount of
money did you feel like you kind of like
you made it or you looked at the number
and you were like
I can't believe this is mine I have this
uh where where was the milestone for you
that it was kind of like your holy [__]
moment uh not until we closed the deal
with uh would turn in believe it or not
I I I I I just never earning on a on an
annual or a monthly or a weekly basis
like is just never to me like that's
just there's always of some some fear in
that you know like you're always just a
little worried that the tap is gonna
turn off and so there was never a moment
where I felt comfortable like spending
or splurging on something which Sam goes
back to your point like yeah there were
times when I said if I could afford this
I would buy it but like I probably could
have afforded it but could I have
afforded it and then my business and
then YouTube slows down and then I have
to deal with the depreciation of it like
a new Lambo would be cool right but if
that loses 200 Grand in the first two
years I couldn't mentally justify that
same with the new AMG wagon I've always
wanted one but there were 150 000 when
they were new well was I comfortable
losing 50 Grand in a year mentally no
because I was always afraid the tap
might turn off you know at the YouTube
channel
did you and when originally when you
launched cars and bids I was a big fan
of bring a trailer
um bring a trailer is similar to you uh
different different audience but I think
I heard rumors that when they sold it
was like 300 million dollars and when
you go to bring your trailer.com it
looks just like a blog like it's a very
like
it doesn't look like a sophisticated
business when in reality it is and when
you launched I was like yeah this is
awesome
but of course we'll do a lot of like
critics were like well but this this
thing already exists and so like what
Insight did you have to go down this
path and also who did you partner with
early on because I don't think that
you're a tech person right no no not at
all as you can see from my video editing
and you heavy usage of iMovie
um no uh yeah bring a trailer is it does
exist and they're huge and they were
huge then and they're even Huger now
um and
that was the hurdle what Insight did we
have none what were we thinking in
retrospect I honestly Wonder like what
what was going through our minds
thinking we could compete with them the
only Insight we had was that we had
heard
I love bring a trailer and I think they
run a great business and they have some
great cars and I have sold cars on there
and whatever but I we had heard from
that there was some dissatisfaction I
think at the end of the day bring a
trailer had gotten so massive that like
stuff was taking a long time to get
listed there were like you said the
quality of the it's a WordPress blog
ultimately it had caught it caused
people some issues you know in sellers
and buyers and the functionality of it
everything and we kind of thought to
ourselves hey we can do this in our
minds better and we can make it modern
and so one of the big things that was
our Focus was doing cars just from the
1980s and up like more modern era cars
we we thought hey if we come with a
modern website and focus on a modern
audience maybe we can kind of exist in a
sort of a different space than bring a
trailer where it's like more Millennial
younger people focused on these types of
cars and I think that that has largely
teased out although now we're starting
to kind of eat some of the bringing
trailer Cars we just posted a
Lamborghini Countach on the site today
like we're going down that road a little
bit more more and who did you partner
with early on I mean when I was doing
research for the original pod I remember
I went to the person's LinkedIn I was
like I gotta figure out who he's working
with like so yeah what was that
relationship and you know how did it
come about you know it's an interesting
thing um I get I had my email address is
in all my videos it's like a Yahoo it's
just it's done tomorrow yeah right and
to be clear like my personal email
address is not on Yahoo but that's the
email address for all the people who are
going to send me emails because as you
can imagine I get when you post your
email address that publicly you get some
weird stuff going on you know yeah
people think they know you what's it
called uh people you know we get that
Shawn and I get it all the time what's
it called a parasocial relationship
right that's exactly people email me and
be like hey man I'm making 84 Grand a
year I got two kids one of them's in
private school thinking about leaving my
wife what car you think I should get and
I'm like
that's true but so I got it I so I get
random emails and so a viewer emailed me
named Blake and he said hey I know I
know we live close by in San Diego I
have this car you ever you know if you
ever want to get dinner and this was
before I had a a kid and I I would I
would meet up with random I did this
many many times probably a hundred times
I met up with just random people on the
internet just it was how I made friends
when we would move to New cities and so
I met up with him and I learned that he
did something in Tech which is how
non-tech people View All Tech people you
know and so and so um it hit me that I
kind of wanted to do this only a couple
of months after our meeting and I called
him and I was like hey I know you do
something in Tech can we do this and
what do you think of this and he had
actually just sold the car and bring a
trailer and kind of recognize some of
the deficiencies and he said yeah this
is a great idea and so we used some seed
money from his company to kind of just
get get off the ground and get started
and then we launched and and right away
we were quickly earning revenue and
quickly profitable was any of the what
was the split so I I always wanted this
about Creator kind of businesses where
it's like are you just promotion or do
you have to do anything with operations
uh are you
do you have to put in money what's the
equity split how did you guys decide
kind of roles and then the the ownership
split
it was tough to decide and there was a
lot of back and forth and it kind of
almost killed the thing but I ended up
with with sort of a substantial majority
because I was even though they had put
down the money I was coming with the
audience and one of the interesting
things I think about these businesses
you mentioned bring a trailer and how
could you compete with it you would be
shocked at how many other auction sites
have shown up and failed since we
launched
um most of them never even make it on
anybody's radar of course we watch them
like a hawk because it's like our
business but you'd be stunned at how
many of these have shown up and we
learned that like you can make a great
product and that's important and we did
that but like having an audience showing
up with an audience is so crucial for
the success of this and that's what
caused all the other ones to fail and so
um that as a result of that I think they
understood that a large portion of the
value at least initially was me and so
even though there was sort of a tangling
in it um I ended up with with the
majority and yes I ended up doing an
enormous amount of operations work like
I was personally the first few weeks I
was approving or denying all the cars
that got submitted we didn't know it
would blow up so much right away is what
happens I think you got a thousand in
one day right it was like the craziest
day of my life we got a thousand and you
get like a you gave like a three
sentence description of each car yeah
that was another thing what the hell was
I thinking marrying myself to that idea
but um what happened was when we first
launched we had this we had this idea
that in order to attract sellers we
would offer a thousand dollars for the
first 50 cars on the site and 500 for
the next 50 cars on site it was a
brilliant idea it was it was spending
whatever that works out to be 75 grand
or whatever but it was the greatest 75
grand we ever spent because we got so
many submissions right away however
um then we had to deal with them and boy
was that
so it's a day and it was all me doing it
basically that's a nightmare and what's
the what's the business model the
business model is you uh probably if I I
don't remember exactly but is it that
buyers buyers of cars have to give you
like three or four or five percent of
the total purchase price that's right
sellers pay nothing buyers pay four and
a half percent
um and now we've got a few other kind of
drivers of Revenue as well there's a
shipping component we just launched
inspections which is really cool sellers
can get their cars inspected
um which we have already seen increases
the number of bids and then the sale
price and everything so that's I think
it'll be a big
um benefit going forward
um but mainly it's that yes that the we
get this buyer's fee and then of course
we've now rolled up the businesses into
one business that the YouTube channel
and the auction site and so obviously my
content revenue is a is a part of the
business too and you did I I believe in
2021 you did like something like 75
million in gross sales yeah that feels
right I should always the numbers but
yeah it looks like the first month so
you get this immediate surge of of
listings but you know getting a
Marketplace off the ground could be hard
but I I suspect with your audience and
it kind of just took off probably fairly
quickly what what do you remember
anything about that first month what
were the numbers
oh yeah the first car was your car right
yeah it was my car that's right the
first car was my car and I've since sold
four or five
um although I haven't bought yet I gotta
do that
um the first month was chaos I mean it's
like you hear from any startup founder
um who's successful right which is that
that that it was absolute chaos we had
we had the good problem of not having
planned for what would come uh the
success that came but the bad problem of
then having to do it on the Fly and we
were hiring people like talking to them
on we didn't even have an office it was
coveted we launched in June of 20. there
were no offices we did this we launched
the whole business from my back patio
and so we're like talking to people in
the pool I mean this was the whole
situation was a complete disaster
um and that month was definitely the
most chaotic and most ridiculous of my
entire well the first two months really
and we started to build more of an
infrastructure and more of a team and
that kind of started to make things
easier but I was still like in the
ground on the trip in the on the ground
in the tree is doing everything
um until the churnan investment came and
we got a little more cash and we could
finally start like putting people in
their roles and I could go back to my
biggest asset to the business which is
of course you know doing talk a little
bit about the sale how'd that come about
how that's a high stakes negotiation
probably the biggest hand of Poker
you've ever played uh tell us some fun
stories about the uh the process and
then the ultimate sale what went down
you know I was really lucky that I had
Blake who who has been in the kind of
the business world the startup world
before and sort of held my hand through
the process because I was just a
clueless I mean at the end of the day I
make YouTube videos for a living like I
shouldn't be involved in any sort of
high eight-figure private Equity deal
like that's not where I live you know so
I hate people so they came to us and and
by the way we hear your fidget spinner
or whatever you got there on the mic
there you go away this is a Toyota Mega
Cruiser we um they came to us and you
know we had gotten as you can imagine we
had a lot of people reach out to us
um because we had kind of grown and it
became clear quickly and then the car
market started to blow up and all these
pevc type firms were like we gotta get
in on this we gotta get on this today
and here's this business that's actually
succeeding doing it and bring a trailer
had just sold to Hearst and so all these
other companies were like are we missing
something we got to go and then you know
what's what's out there we could start
it ourselves or this exists so we could
a lot of reach outs but we viewed it as
like kind of BS we were like we're too
small to make this make sense to anybody
um and so we kind of ignored them all
but the Turning group was really
persistent
and finally they kind of got intro to us
through a friend and I thought to myself
well I can't say no to this call if it
came to a friend I'll just take it it'll
be 10 minutes and I'll hang out I took
it in the car and um but they told me
the most interesting thing I wasn't
familiar with the children group but
they told me that they specifically
worked with creator-led businesses and
that was a huge like light bulb moment
for me because my big fear of working
with any ervc companies they're going to
come in and they're going to say we got
to change this this and this on your
YouTube channel and it's going to look
like this now and this is how it's going
to work and even if it was a big payday
for me I feel like I didn't want to have
to explain to someone how YouTube works
you know like I just wanted I felt like
I could do it better myself but these
guys knew already how it worked and they
were going to be like your audience it's
already working this isn't how we don't
want to screw with anything and that was
a big moment hearing that they like
specialize in this and so going forward
that that just sort of began the
conversation and one thing led to
another that kind of went through here's
how we might do it you know we kind of
gave them some Basics they gave us a
term shade and it it it came to fruition
were you able to take money off the
table or did it go to the uh go to the
business yeah no I took I took money off
I bought that career GT and and uh so it
was a nice it was a nice situation for
me to be able to do that especially
after a lot a lot of hard work and
actually in the end I feel like this is
the best time because I got enough money
that I can kind of chill a little bit
and I swear there's something nice about
that in terms of running and operating a
business like this you make way more
money when you have that like when you
could chill a little bit you know like
the less you want it the more you get it
I feel like that's true like I feel like
I'm I'm more relaxed I'm by focusing on
like myself a little bit more and then
I'm in a better mental state to like
make better decisions and do more things
and in the end it's actually been
beneficial even though you would think
it would be the opposite if you're
chasing money you'd you'd work harder
and maybe I did work harder but I think
I'm working better now have you ever
heard of the phrase uh trade a mean
keeping Keen so like I remember when I
was when I was like 16 I was like I was
telling someone I was like I want to
meet I was telling my a friend a
girlfriend uh who is like this really
pretty girl I was like man I want to
meet more girls and she goes you got to
treat them me to keep them Keen you know
the less you want it the more you're
gonna get it and I was like oh thank you
like it's a I tried way less hard and I
got way more girls the same is true with
money I treat him I treat it mean and I
keep it Keen you know the money comes to
me the more that I don't want it that
sounds like something an aunt would say
no 14 year old is hitting me with that
quote when you say I want to meet more
girls uh yeah she was like a like
someone like a neighbor you know she was
in like college at the time and uh yeah
and I was like man I'm trying to try to
meet these girls I read the book the
game I'm doing all the stuff I'm trying
to I've tried hard and she was like you
got to treat me to keep a Keem she's
like you just gotta care less you don't
do nothing we're still using that phrase
all these years later it's still
relevant how does this work though like
if I'm this may be a question for for
Mike and those guys at turning but like
you buy a Creator lead business
Critter wants to go chill on the beach
now you gave him give him millions and
millions of dollars but you need their
face still it's tied to their face is
there like a long transition plan where
you you it's like blippi where they just
changed out the guy a different guy came
in and started wearing the stuff on
YouTube and everyone in the comments is
like hey uh that's not blippi
um what's the plan
you know I've been on I've done a few
podcasts and interviews and all sorts of
things with after this deal is closed
and you're I think about your question
constantly and you're the first person
on one of these who's actually asked it
to me because yeah I think they're nuts
I truly think they're crazy like if you
really think about it the best answer if
you really think about it like like the
whole it's a great idea when it works
and for them it's worked wonderfully and
I suspect that relates to the diligence
they do on the Creator like they they
know that I'm not gonna do that right
because they know me they got to know me
through this process it took like six
eight months and we really got to know
each other and they realized I wasn't
about to just bail and go sit on the
beach or do something insane like start
saying crazy stuff on Twitter and get
canceled whatever they knew that but
like I could like I still if I were them
I'd be terrified like they're making
massive investments into businesses that
have dudes like me who could just go off
the rails one day and I think that is a
crazy business model but they would
torque by saying hey we do the diligence
but also like this is how businesses are
going to be like creators have these
audiences this is where people want to
get their stuff whatever it is Kitchen
products cars doesn't matter they want
to get it from people who they love and
who they care about Mr Beast Burger you
know all that stuff and so if you're
gonna do it you gotta take that risk and
but the benefit is you don't have to
spend a lot in like paid marketing
because the audience is there and they
want to be there and so there's like a
huge benefit to that but also a very
scary potential drop we've had we've had
Mr Beast on the Pod uh we recently did
an episode with uh Danny Austin who
created a hair hair care brand basically
a scalp brand
um also doing really really well what
Creator brands are awesome to you that
you think have done a good job is there
any that stand out or you took
inspiration from
that's a good question you know when we
when we launched this when we came up
with the idea and launched this in the
summer of 19 it wasn't as common like
it's having a Creator kind of pivot into
a brand was like less of a thing
a lot of guys were doing a lot of guys I
say guys because I was car people but
just generally people were doing merge
that was a big thing and some of them
even had lines of products whatever but
they the pivoting of doing this has
become more of a thing since then and so
I wouldn't say any of them were
necessarily an inspiration it was more
that I was just terrified that I had
this giant audience and if I didn't do
something with them they were going to
start to go away eventually and I had to
do something and so that was more based
out of fear and anxiety than like than
like being inspired by someone which is
great
um but obviously since then a lot of
others have come and I give this advice
to everybody I know everybody in this
space all of my card creator friends I
tell them like start a business start a
business start a business you never know
when your audience is going to go away
please like take your audience right now
and start a business do something and
they they look at me like I'm nuts some
of the time because they're like what do
you mean I'm already traveling five days
a week filming and doing all this stuff
and editing late at night doing I you
know writing scripts how can I start a
business on top of that and my answer is
like
I don't know but you gotta you gotta
figure it out because that's the that's
the next way to take what you're doing
[Music]
spot is a CRM platform so it shares its
data across every application every team
can stay aligned no out of sync
spreadsheets or dueling databases
HubSpot grow better
have you seen I want to ask you about
two ideas have you seen have you guys
seen um what's it called uh exotic car
hacks I think it's called no dude it's
the the guy I I think that he's like
playing a douche on TV I think he's like
trying to be an [__] like this is so
his whole he's definitely this guy's
like a total jerk but he uh he's got
this course I think it's a course I
don't know if it's a community or it's a
course but you pay a little bit of money
and he teaches you how to hack exotic
cars which I have not taken it I think
what it means is like you buy a car
that's like four or five years old
usually around the twenty thousand
dollar uh or Twenty Thousand Mile range
and then you drive it for one year and
you could sell it and you have hopefully
only you know you you've mostly broke
even I think he also has a thing where
you can like become a licensed dealer
which I don't understand how that works
but I heard a rumor that he sold the
course to PE is that true or totally
made up I don't know I I haven't heard
that have you seen that Sean yeah are
you looking at this guy now but his
YouTube Banner is like uh Tim is a Grand
Theft Auto character so that's that's
solid to start and then I think you're
right it's basically like how it says
learn how to buy sell and trade exotic
cars for Fun and Profit uh which is
honestly it's a good good Niche
um in fact my only criticism of this guy
is uh he doesn't look douchey enough
like once you go into the video he's
just like a guy wearing like a v-neck he
doesn't look like yeah he's just gotta
be like no dude he's like uh I watched
the video he was like like 10 times more
jewelry than he's wearing like this guy
he needs to piss me off but also make me
want him right like that's the trick
well
he was driving a Land Rover Defender and
he goes see the problem with the Land
Rover Defender is my watch is worth five
times this Defender the audio he's a
verbal dude he goes even though it looks
cool I can't decide if I'm poor because
five of these still wouldn't equal the
price of my watch well I think more
people should do this I so so Doug our
uh one of the companies I built we got
bought by twitch when I was at twitch
you know you spend a bunch of time on
Twitch and you see what people are doing
and it was like everybody's kind of
doing a very similar thing it's like
um you know there's like two classes of
people there's like you know really good
at the game three classes say really
good at the game people watch them
because they're so awesome at the game
and they can actually have no
personality people just like them
because their aim is good and then you
have people that are super cute right
hot girls they do well too and then you
have uh like the third Group which is
like super likable like kind of the
group you're in I would I would say
where it's like they're not they're not
like the most technically good at the
game but they're likable they're fun
they play they're called a variety
streamer they stream a bunch of
different games they keep it interesting
good good fan interaction and there was
one guy that just took it a whole
different direction this guy doctor
disrespect have you seen him yeah I've
heard of him so he created a whole
character he comes on and he he himself
was like a college basketball player so
he's like six eight so he's this huge
guy but he wears this like mullet wig he
wears like a bulletproof vest like a red
bulletproof he looks like a character
from the 80s and he created his name he
created his thing Dr disrespect and then
he has like he's catch phrases he was
basically a wrestling character so he
basically was like the rock where he
would um he had this Persona and he had
these catch phrases and then everybody
in his life became a character his wife
became a character like if she would
come on the screen like you would never
see her only her hand and she would feed
him while he was playing like feeding
him grapes basically and he would do
everything ridiculous and then to add to
that he would like go sit courtside at
an NBA game but dressed fully as Dr
disrespect and that investment of like
that five thousand dollar Courtside seat
was actually really valuable to building
this Persona this brand of like and he
always called himself in the 1994 or
1995 two-time Blockbuster NBA Jam
whatever like Champion like he's got
these like phrases that he would always
go to just purposely trying to be
hateable yeah just trying to be like
exactly he created a whole character and
he just stayed like when he stayed with
him Floyd when Floyd Mayweather became
Money Mayweather exactly like I'm going
full heel exactly but even more like it
was more like wrestling because he's got
a costume also like on top of the whole
thing and I actually think that for
Content creators it's surprising you
don't see more of this like yeah that's
such a good point there are these
archetypes like in wrestling you have
the the faces the good guys you got the
heels the guys that are intentionally
bad guys that are gonna get a big
following because you'll love to hate
them Floyd Mayweather did this in boxing
he was not making any money and he uh he
became Floyd Money Mayweather this
obnoxious arrogant you know money in
your face guy then he started getting
really really popular because people
wanted to see him lose there's a guy in
the UFC that did the same thing he uh
he's basically about to get cut the UFC
told him you're too boring we're going
to cut you and so that night he went on
and he just started saying all this
offensive stuff on the microphone
against Brazilians and this one fighter
and whatever and they were like well now
we got to keep him to fight that guy
because he just created a feud and he's
like this guy just took it to the like
to you know to level 10 of being this
heel I I'm surprised there's not more of
this on YouTube you know the best car
guy who's doing that right now is this
guy whistling Diesel have you ever seen
his I love whistling diesel I heard that
he's a sweetheart by the way there is no
car content creator who I like more than
whistling diesel I've never met him tell
Sean tell Sean what he does dude
it's the it's like Mr Beast but like for
cars and he and he just does things that
make people hate him so he buys a
Ferrari to destroy it and he put it you
know you know you can buy those as an
example you know you can buy those
garage bubbles like like Boomers have
you know they put their old corvetteum
inside their garage it's like a it's
like an inflatable bubble that makes
sure nobody ever touches the car he
bought one of those for his Ferrari and
just started throwing stuff at it
ladders and shovels and and
sledgehammers song just see if it worked
it would off-road the Ferrari he put
giant 20 foot tall wagon wheels on his
Tesla I mean all sorts of just dumb
stuff and I just am obsessed with it I'm
like this is the kind of content I wish
I was making
how does he how does this guy afford it
I assume I assume he's doing the same
thing that Mr Beast is doing where he's
taking basically all of the money that
he's pulling in from revenue and from
you know
placement ad placements and just putting
it right back into doing more dumb crap
like you dropped the G wagon into a
house when he was in the G way I mean
everything it's just incredible it's
incredible content there's uh what are
some of the titles uh using 35 000 Nike
Air Mags as work boots so he bought
extremely rare extremely expensive shoes
it's just a great walk around in the mud
with them doing work uh there's extreme
School Bus off-roading he takes a bus
and he's just like flying around but
it's also number one so I guess that's a
series I guess there's gonna be a lot
more of those uh to come driving a Tesla
upside down
parentheses 10 foot tall Wheels okay I
don't know what that is that's that's
amazing but each of these has like five
to ten million views so it's very
incredible it's incredible content and
he's just this kid from like Indiana or
like rural Pennsylvania who just if he
wasn't doing this he'd be like driving a
truck you know but instead he like
decided to become hateful on in on
YouTube and he's killing it and I love
it yeah he's great to see people hate
him there is nothing more fun than these
people that guy's so irresponsible and
it's like yeah that's been fun it's
YouTube yeah you're supposed to be
responsible supposed to be a little he
took like um like a 250 000 G wagon and
which is like everyone says it's an
off-road vehicle but like no one drives
a G-Wagon off-road and he like you know
destroys it like to the point where it's
smoking and he just annihilates this
G-Wagon how much revenue do you think
that this guy's Channel makes so I want
to know if he is if he is putting all of
it back into the videos I want to know
how much that budget is
he's getting 20 million views a month so
I suspect he's probably pulling in
you know yeah one to two million a month
and then he does AD placements and they
must get tons of money because his views
get so uh his videos get so many views
wait at 20 million views a month you
think he's making let me let me review a
million it's in I don't know in in his
in his world I don't know because his
audience is good as I suspect you're
very different from mine my audience
doing car reviews is really high dollar
content because you're in market car
Shoppers and that is a very desirable
demographic for advertisers whistling
Diesel's probably there's probably a lot
of kids there's probably more foreign
audience than mine so probably doesn't
make as much but he's he's probably
doing all right and plus he lives in the
middle of nowhere in like World
Pennsylvania so his cost of living is
like he's good he's damaging what would
a good CPM be from AdSense for your
YouTube video that's a good question I
don't remember anymore I actually
calculated CPM in this completely
different way because I never understood
why it was views like dollars per
thousand views it never really made
sense to me so I started calculating the
number reviews I had to get to earn a
dollar and so good for me was a video
that broke a hundred with a hundred
marks so less than 100 views to earn a
dollar
um and there were there were a lot of
videos especially in December when ad
rates were strong that were that were
pulling in that that's so funny that's
how you calculated that makes it
actually makes a lot of sense because it
makes more sense to me yeah like I feel
like everything you've told me so far is
like um just a guy like sort of using
his intuition like like you're just like
well like uh like I had a friend that
was like I had a friend that would do
this he'd be like um
you know it like he would keep like his
money like instead of like going to a
bank selling a bank account then like oh
you should invest it he's like no I have
three shoe boxes and like shoebox one is
spend money and shoebox two is save
money and he cut his own bank account in
my dorm room and he was just like yeah
like you know but you if you're gonna
move one to this box you got to put two
in the other box it's just like I'm like
dude I think you're actually just using
the normal like personal finance rules
but you just are but you but you backed
into that yeah you did them like a guy
like you know like a caveman like just
sort of discovering fire here that's
probably true for me but I I will say
like in my in my view that's kind of how
YouTube was it from like 13 to 19. the
before like a lot of big businesses
started showing up and really maximizing
the hell out of everything I think it
was a lot of people just kind of
randomly using intuition to like make
decisions and it was like okay that
video did well so I'm gonna try this
video instead of like really thinking
through okay the thumbnail should say
this at this pixel and all that which is
how we a lot of creators do it now it
was a lot of just like yeah let's give
this a shot and for some people it
worked out and those are the people that
you end up talking to and for some
people it didn't and those are the ones
who sizzled out did you and do you now
have a video team I read somewhere that
you were editing up you're editing them
up until cars and bids and then now you
just have an editor but like is that
true or do you have like a Booker
because I know you're on the road or at
least you said one annual wrap up you're
like I traveled like uh you know most
weeks yeah well when I lived in Philly I
was traveling a ton because the weather
but now I'm in California and it's
gotten a lot easier
um yeah so it was just me so I launched
the channel in 13 we went to two videos
a week in 16. it was just me up until we
launched the Royal the Royal you say we
yeah we when we I my fam I think of my
wife as part of this because boy has
that been a journey for her but um so so
I launched the channel in 13 and there
have always been kind of people around
friends who helped shoot things that
kind of thing so there's a Wii component
to that too but mostly it was just me
and then in March of 20 when we all
launched cars and bids I realized like
that week that I was never going to be
able to edit another video again and so
I called a guy who had emailed me like a
year before like hey do you need an
editor and I always kind of ignore those
emails and I was like are you still
available and can you start today and
his answer was yeah and he's still my
editor uh it's been now over three years
you just had a baby
and um
but now we have more people also because
we're going to start doing more content
and so we hired like a a video kind of
content manager who's going to oversee I
think it's going to be multiple channels
mine the Carson bids Channel and then
like new creators come in and stuff and
I just don't have the WHERE with all the
bandwidth especially because I want to
continue doing what I'm doing and I just
don't really have the ability to like
also manage a whole thing have you guys
heard of uh more plates more dates have
you know who that is uh all right so his
name's Derek he's probably maybe as
famous as you but in like the fitness
genre he's like on Joe Rogan and stuff
whatever yeah and he has a great video
but his video a you don't know his last
name you just know it's Derek at more
plates more dates and B his videos it's
just him like on a camera kind of like
you are right now but it's just a plain
white background like it looks like
you're just at like like he's in like a
college dorm or he's just like in his
house just goofing around but his videos
get millions and millions of views and I
heard a rumor
that now his businesses are making many
many tens of millions a year in Revenue
but the room that he originally started
this YouTube video or this YouTube
channel it was just like a like a shitty
old apartment when he didn't have a lot
of money and they took the wall out of
the apartment and he has since moved to
a significantly larger very nice home
but they try to transpose it so it looks
exactly like the old one and that's kind
of like what you have to do so like they
don't want people to think like Oh Derek
is like killing me now he's unrelatable
and that's sort of like I imagine you've
kind of lucked into this situation where
it's like oh my whole shtick is that
like I'm quirky and the videos aren't
well edited therefore I can keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger without
like doing anything that sophisticated
there's a component of that also that
it's worked so like in a sense I don't
really want to change it that much
because as much as that is kind of like
the the stick it's like also been
successful
um but yeah it's one I one drawback of
this and I think about Jerry Seinfeld a
lot when I think about this Seinfeld's
humor is all based on a normal guy doing
stuff he's no longer and hasn't been for
decades the normal guy and I bet it's
gotten harder for him to make jokes like
hey you ever get to the FBO or the
private plane you know and it's late and
you're like damn like you can't so how
do you do that and so for me I'm like
it's it it hasn't gotten harder but I do
feel sad that like I'm no longer like
your neighbor who's like here's how you
should think of this card because here's
how I think of this car no I'm a guy
who's got you know a career GT or will
afford and it's like okay well maybe
he's not quite as you know when he talks
about supercars being slow it's like
well screw this guy you know because
it's a little bit less relatable but I
still like to think that I'm you know
Chris and Chris Rock's most recent
comedy special he says I'm rich but I
identify as poor and I kind of like feel
that way to an extent because like this
didn't I didn't start this way like I
still remember I still wear these stupid
clothes because like that's what I wear
it's not like I've like she's gone I'm
not like wearing like high-end stuff and
then when the camera turns off like
that's just who I am and so I think to
an extent it's still it's still pretty
genuine by the way Sean uh Carrera GT
it's like a one point something million
dollar car it's like uh the car
enthusiasts love it it's like a lot of
people's dream car Doug but you're the
type of guy who like uh I imagine shows
up in a million and a half dollar car
wearing cargo shorts yeah oh yeah a
white T-shirt that's dirty and old New
Balance he's got like you've got to be
the only guy over three and a half
Pockets per uh per leg that's exactly
where I'm driving everywhere I go I wear
my stupid shorts and t-shirt and like
you can think what you want I'm driving
career yeah
and yeah I don't know if you've seen
this Sean but on his videos the true
fans they'll put stuff at the top of
video like Doug's the type of guy who
licks his finger before he turns the
page on his iPad like
like he's got he's got to think I'm like
this geeky like cautious person which is
probably accurate to be honest I just
love at the end of the day people are
like the quirks and features thing what
a great idea like this wasn't an idea I
really just love like seeing how buttons
work in cards like that is genuinely and
you know what's funny like I shoot all
these videos now for the site you know
we're selling cars on the site and there
are new cars that have gonna have big
audiences and like I show up to film and
I like still have this feeling in me
every single time shooting an Acura NSX
right after this and I still have this
feeling like I'm really excited to see
the quirks of this car like it's still
in my mind after all these years and so
I feel like I'm probably doing the right
the right job
does it uh well how does it feel to be
wealthy now
after after grinding after this for so
long it's better than before it is it is
definitely nice
aside from that car I didn't like
splurge on anything I kind of like live
a certain life and that's sort of how
it's going to be but um but it is nice
to have a little I think I am a little
bit more anxious about money than a lot
of people and it's nice to not have any
of that anxiety anymore and I'll tell
you it came at the perfect time because
I just had a boy and like it's amazing
to be able to like
detach and just like be with him without
having to worry about like grinding for
the next video every little dollar you
know that I place this thing perfectly
in this video
um it's a it's like an amazing sequence
of events do you think um how big is
this business going to get I mean I
think I I by the way Sean have you seen
brigad trailer it's basically like yeah
a Blog I think it is actually in fact
WordPress yeah by the way the whole time
we've been doing this interview I've
also just been shopping cars and bids so
I'm like currently like my finger is
hovering over this 1994 Toyota hiace
Super custom wagon this I can just buy
this van for five thousand dollars and
I'm very very tempted to do this this is
pretty sweet looking van I don't know
why I want this but I really really want
it it's awesome the site's awesome I'm
looking at uh you have this like three
wheeler a vanderhall because I was
looking at a Morgan three-wheeler or do
I need to close this tab it's buy or
close the tab those are my two options
right right exactly that's kind of the
fun of it well you you bring a trailer
which was before you guys it was
basically just a Blog I don't know if
you know the show but the guy who
started it his name was one guy's name
is Randy but the other partner was
Gentry Underwood who started mailbox
that's that company that sold I think
for a hundred million dollars pre-launch
to Dropbox and I emailed him because he
used to have throttle yard which was
that for motorcycles it had all the
stuff and I was like tell me about this
business uh bring a trailer and he says
it's the hardest slog like it was the
hardest thing ever to get going it took
years and years and years and then I
heard a rumor that it sold for many
hundreds of millions of dollars do you
know what it sold for Doug I have an
idea but I'm not gonna speculate on
Randy's business was it to uh private
Equity or who bought it Hearst First
Media but like half of it is our
understanding am I often saying that I
that like it's probably I think the
valuation was in the hundreds of
millions but I don't I I don't know
exactly how much anybody ended up with
or whatever but
um but they did well Randy killed it
they're killing it now the the sale was
was
um by the car business standards the
sale was relatively early
um in the sense that they sold kind of
right before things went crazy in 21 and
they've ramped Bay and us I mean as a
function of this Market that's been so
crazy have ramped like crazy since then
and so I think the business is worth
quite a lot more now I suspect what do
you think is going to happen with you
guys I mean do you think like
are you thinking you know this is a a
multi-billion dollar opportunity I don't
know I honestly I never thought I'd get
here don't you have to make it that now
if you if you I I think you sold I don't
know what you sold you sold it just said
majority majority for 40 million which I
I you know that puts the valuation in
the 60 to 80 million range I imagine I
mean you need like a I imagine they're
looking for like a 500 million plus
outcome then I think I think we'd all be
happy at 500 million yeah I don't I but
and I think that there's a pathway to
get there and frankly I think bring a
trailer showing that and I think that
also the
um reality of this space is that this is
how it's going like
the internet made it easier to buy and
sell cars obviously it used to be in the
newspaper and that was kind of a
disaster with low information on both
sides and everything and now the
internet shows up Craigslist shows up
that's one thing and now people are
starting to realize that there is
significant value in these auction sites
because sellers can amplify they can get
you know to a much larger audience than
they could on their own website or an
AutoTrader and buyers can get a larger
selection frankly than having to visit
every single dealer's website and every
single whatever or go to physical
auctions like Mecum and those are you
know what are you going to show up there
you know like that's not realistic for a
lot of people this is kind of becoming
the new way so I honestly don't know I
think if you would ask Randy eight years
ago he never would have thought his
business would have gotten this big and
but this is the market is growing along
with these businesses another
interesting person in your space who I
think that you have a feud with but I
don't know why but when Sean bought his
car I think he did he watched your video
and then he dm'd this guy named uh car
dealer guy is that what it's called a
car dealership
car dealership guy so basically the
story behind this is Sean and I have
been obsessed with so Sean and I are
both popular on Twitter we've been
obsessed with this idea of like look
there's gonna be a billionaire YouTuber
Mr Beast at least is getting there it
might be around that
um there we've seen that happen on
Facebook we've seen billion dollar
companies on Facebook we've seen that on
Instagram no one's done it on Twitter
but it will happen and in particular
we're interested in these like there's
like these guys called like the guys so
there's like the strip mall guy he talks
about investing in strip malls there's
the watch guy who talks about old
watches and we're like what's gonna
happen with these quote guys like what
are they what are they gonna do and then
there's the anonymous car dealer guy and
I think Sean like dm'd him asking like
which car should I buy and he told him
to get the Cadillac and then he watched
your review and then he just wired some
guy money and got the Cadillac what do
you think first of all I don't know why
I said I want to buy this car I'm
looking for this car can he find it for
me and buy it for me and get it to my
house and I don't want to do any work
and he did it he did exactly that
um okay here's here's the they'll tell
you the Genesis of the feud and then
I'll tell you what I think of that
um the here's the thing about success on
Twitter
for for one of those guys
and I love all those guy tweet twitters
I think they're all really interesting
including car dealership guy but the
problem is in order to be successful on
Twitter and I have a suspicion that this
is even more true in the new age of
Twitter
you've got to be really controversial
and you got to be pretty like I wouldn't
say Blasphemous but you got to be like
out there with like your takes and your
opinions because that amplifies more and
I think Facebook found out years ago
that like they can do that but that
doesn't necessarily lead to a great
community and a lot of times there was
all this election misinformation or all
this fear-mongering and so they like
dialed back some of that and it sounds
to me like Twitter right now is actually
magnifying it like it seems every crazy
take is at the top with all these
engagements and that's what they're
trying to maximize for and the problem
that I have with car dealership guy is
that like his if you read his posts some
of them are just like the most insane
through marketing stuff you'll ever read
like The reason we got into the feud was
I he posted like Ford has done this
crazy thing they're gonna go out of
business it's gonna be the worst thing
in the world and I'm like this is this
is so insane and I went into the data of
what he was talking about and Ford had
to do some big write down on some
investment this year and so their
profits were low and he didn't mention
that he only mentioned that the profits
were off 80 compared to last year and it
was like maybe a little bit or he'll say
like he'll say like uh uh lease lease uh
I forget what it's called when you can't
pay your lease but uh link lease
delinquency is like at this time which
is the highest it's ever been which
means in four months something like
everything is gonna blow up and yeah and
I think the problem I have with all of
those guy accounts is precisely and so I
I called him out on this Ford thing and
we got into a little a little tiff and
unfortunately for him everyone who was
replying agreed with me once they saw
the data and so he blocked me and so and
then but and then I realized though I'm
not the only person he has blocked he a
lot of my car journalist friends who I
suspect have also tried to add contacts
at various times he has blocked them
also and so what I suspect happens is
he's like kind of tried to create a
little bit of an echo chamber around
himself because that's what makes you
popular on Twitter now if you go into
somebody's tweets and you see that they
have a lot of like well that's amazing
types of replies they're going to
continue to get magnified and get blown
out and I think that people who have a
lot of dissent it starts to become a
little bit cloudier and but if you see
somebody as like a real icon where
everybody's agreeing with him then it
continues to make and seem more and more
like elevated and I so I suspect he's
blocking other people who disagree and
so I I in in an idea I like the idea of
that Twitter account but I think in
order to be popular I don't I don't even
dislike him I dislike the concept of in
order to be popular on Twitter you kind
of have to just keep going controversial
and these crazy takes and that's really
the only way to like make it work and I
think that that's less true on the other
platforms
yeah I think that's true we have a
friend named Nick who owns uh or part
owns an agency that outsources a lot of
like uh assistant like executive
assistant work to the Philippines and
he'll do these tweets where he brags
about paying his workers five dollars an
hour and how that empowers them and and
everything like that which like is or is
not true I I imagine it is true but he
says it in such a way where he knows
people are going to get angry and share
it and at the bottom of the Tweet he'll
be like by the way uh if this actually
interests you you could like sign up
here and so he'll like tweet something
that gets like it'll go it goes viral
every time like he'll get like you know
50 000 likes and like you know three or
four or 500 quotes of like people saying
this guy is such a douche can you
believe how tone deaf he is whatever and
then he'll like text us he goes made 50
Grand a day exactly that's that's the
problem I have with Twitter at least
right now I think it's definitely gone
to more of a
controversy cells kind of thing you
can't just be like a nice dude and do
well on Twitter right now you have to
have like takes that are controversial
and kind of ridiculous in order to get
anywhere and I'm just I don't know it's
a shame I want to ask you one one last
inside baseball question which was um
Sean you probably don't this probably
doesn't entirely interest you but maybe
I think it would for you Doug have you
noticed that a lot of car museums are
non-profits so for example there's like
the barber Museum in I think Alabama
yeah where so it's a non-profit you can
go on and like see their financials and
everything and I have a feeling and this
is like an interesting tax hack but I
don't know if it's true I have a feeling
what they do is they sell a business
sort of like we've all done and what
you've recently done Doug and they put
their money I think in some type of like
Donor advised fun which is like you can
uh give away a certain amount of money
to certified non-profits and then reduce
your tax burden and I have a feeling
what they're doing is they're setting up
their car museum as a non-profit and
like the barber guy I believe he set up
the barber Museum after he sold I think
like a dairy company for like a billion
dollars he had like a milk and dairy
business I have a feeling what they do
is they make a big sale a big Equity
sale in their business and they put a
certain amount of proceeds into a donor
advice fund of which they've been put
into a non-profit that they own and
that's where they go and buy all their
cars and they let people come and see
their cars and whatever I have a feeling
that's what's happening I don't I don't
know I've just been like looking around
this I think that's what's happening
there's another guy who I think you had
on his his YouTube channels like here's
my 20 million dollar car collection he's
a young guy that has a tire store
and he keeps saying in his YouTube
videos I buy these cars so everyone can
enjoy it and I have a feeling he's doing
the same thing as well you're talking
about huvi I think hoovie's garage
I I can't remember he's in San Diego and
he has a tire store it's an interesting
idea it's an interesting idea I think I
need a larger exit before I can make
that happen but that is a great place to
a great way to justify uh a vehicle
collection I think it's not that you
donate the money I think you have to
donate the asset or your shares to the
daf first but if you but if you control
it and you work in the museum is yours
what do you care I just asked um
I asked Bard the new Google AI I said
explain how rich people use non-profit
museums to avoid paying taxes here's
what it says
that a way that rich people use
nonprofit museums to avoid paying taxes
to create a donor advice on death the
death is a charitable giving account it
allows donors to make a one-time or
recurring distribution of cash or
appreciated assets and receive an
immediate tax deduction
but
um so basically the donor donates art to
like for example donor donates are to a
museum they receive an immediate tax
deduction for the full appraised value
of the art however the museum does not
have to sell the art and they can
instead display it as their own
collection they can avoid paying capital
gains on the appreciation of the art
um and so I think I've seen this where
people basically have like a
quote-unquote public museum like in
their backyard uh it's like and I wonder
how who what who dictates what yeah what
is the monitoring the price but also
like how many hours does the museum have
to be open to justify exactly 45 minutes
yeah 45 minutes a year
like like could you say that like
because this is Doug's Porsche it is now
worth an additional 20 increase you know
what I mean like I wonder I wonder like
what the appraised value is but I had a
feeling that's what's happening which
seems like a wonderful hack for
Cardinals because you can now totally
would that mean that your your purchase
price is effective believe like 37 or
however whatever your your taxes uh
fifty percent
I've been to that barber Museum and it
is quite an operation and so if that's
true there's probably such a massive
spend at the beginning to get if you
don't think it was it was the legal 50
million I believe uh I went and looked
up his all his numbers I think he seed
funded it with 40 or something million
and it makes around 50 million a year
um and man that's crazy non-profits you
can go and uh look up all the
information yeah so there's like I think
there's the Peterson Museum in La
there's a few other ones and you could
actually go and look at all the uh you
can look at their financials and you
could figure out because I that was my
dream was I was like if I get you know a
500 million dollar exit I like it would
be awesome this is what I'm doing this
playground
um but yeah I've already done all the
math and like looked into all this
that's what we got to do that's an
interesting thing never considered it
but will in the future
well Doug we appreciate you coming on
now hopefully uh uh you realize I'm I'm
legitimately a huge fan so yeah I
appreciate that thank you and talk to
you and
um maybe uh Sean's not exactly a car guy
but maybe he will because I hope you
appreciate that I legitimately have only
watched one of your videos but it did
lead me to buy a car so you know enjoy
that escalate it's gonna be great I will
it's only got a 66 on the Doug score now
I'm thinking no that's gonna be maybe I
should be pretty good the best car ever
got like a 73. there's six cars higher
than it and so I'm like am I the kind of
guy who just buys the seventh best
luxury SUVs I bet it's at the very it is
probably my favorite if you're gonna go
down that route
um it's a that's a that's a bit of a
risky car to drive around the bay area
where everybody else is in electric cars
you're getting like 12 miles per gallon
you know oh yeah I love it it's but it
uh I asked him Doug I go so do you have
like the self-driving stuff and you're
like I don't know do I and I was like
that's like the whole point of that
point that's the whole point of that
Escalade is like drive for you isn't
that in the bay that's what you want the
PO the point of it is that it fits
multiple car seats and as huge amount of
trunk space that's that's the point
actually yeah you didn't even know I'm
pretty I'm not trying to self-driving
car myself
the system you have in that car is the
best system of all of all it's better
than Tesla's self-driving how is that
possible absolutely sure unquestionable
because it came from Cruz the Cadillac
system lets you be totally hands-off
Tesla system is not even I would say in
the top four anymore but Cadillac system
is especially good it lets you be fully
hands off as long as you want provided
that you're looking ahead you can be
hands off and and you have to be on a
mapped road but that's like every
Highway if you're if you're on a map
road which like the five and you're
looking ahead you can just sit there and
yeah but like I won't give you ideas
about stuff you can do but you don't
have to be driving no I don't know
you're the car guy I said let me just
but I am the tech guy and I just don't
understand how Cadillac could possibly
have better self-driving because
software they bought Crews they brought
your buddy's company uh Cruise you know
remember remember
they they they bought Crews GM bike
Crews GM owns Cadillac but cruise is not
like Cruz was not the top of the top
right like that that wasn't they they
are some of I mean you'll see cruises in
San Francisco now you can rent a cruise
at the intersection they don't know what
the hell to do at any Interstate have
you seen have you driven around San
Francisco I wouldn't trust it that's the
thing about it the the Cadillac
SuperCrew system works best on and
mostly only on freeways I don't even use
because I have a pretty good system I
have a new Mercedes that has a great
system too and I don't use it once I get
off the freeway I'm driving myself and
that's true of the Teslas also they say
full self-driving but we've seen all
those seen those videos where the cards
yeah I wouldn't trust it off freeway
we're still in a kind of a wild west
situation we didn't look at the defender
Sean you weren't you weren't a Defender
guy is that a Marvel movie what do you
know what you're talking about the
Defenders what are we talking about here
yeah that's the level we're at here with
Sean I dm'd a guy and told him to buy me
a car that's the level of research I did
I picked you didn't look at anything rap
videos dude like
that was my research what about a
minivan would you consider a minivan at
all I wanted a minivan my preference was
a minivan my wife vetoed it because she
was like uh because I'm just like cars
stressed me out nice car stressed me out
so I just wanted something I wouldn't be
stressed about that was super functional
I was like what if we just go the other
way what if we just zag here when
everybody's zigging and we we go get
like the most functional most spacious
ugliest minivan that I'm not gonna worry
about anywhere I could park it anywhere
and I'm just not gonna care what happens
to this car and it's just gonna be this
like transport closet for me and my kids
mess and that's what I was interested in
but my wife was like cool we're not
doing that I recommend minivans to
everybody now everybody with multiple
kids I get a buddy who has three kids
and I was just like I need a van he's
like what SUV can I get I was like you
need a van he was like I could get three
car seats in my car there's there's a
good minivan for me the Sienna is the
one you want that's the one everybody
gets right now that's at the Toyota
Sienna that's the one you want dude is
slow and it is lame but it is if you
have if especially three and up children
three numbers three kids or more you you
just have to getting car seats into an
SUV like it's just I just want like the
Crocs version of a car
yeah that is exactly that but Crocs are
cool yeah I'm betting that the minivan
will make the make a Crocs like come
back no you made the right choice with
the Escalade if although that's like 130
000 SUV which kind of defeats the
purpose of not worrying about it uh yeah
I could I got overrode bye-bye I I got
vetoed by my wife and I had to buy a
good car that I do have to worry about a
little bit and what what do you own
right now Doug I didn't know you owned a
another Mercedes you have the defender
my main normal car I have a uh E-class
station wagon
um so AMG or not an AMG no just an E450
pleb dude we had this exit we had this
giant exit and got all this money and I
went out and bought a used non-amg
E-class stage wagon that is who I am at
heart
um you know the real reason I did that
is because I love the AMG wagon but
ultimately I now have a 4GT a Carrera GT
and then two crazy convertible SUVs and
my view was I don't need to be getting
seven miles per gallon and doing 0-60 in
three seconds in my daily driver it's
just not it's I I'm good I've got cars
that can do all that and so I just
bought a regular one also the regular
ones are just as fast now as the AMG
ones were only a few years ago so I'm
it's it's fine it's comfortable and
Bishop it's so nice do you still draw I
mean I I watched one of your things and
you're like I drove this car across
country six times in the last like two
years why are you driving cross-country
versus flying oh in the summer we live
in Massachusetts and so I drive all the
way across the country every summer and
all the way across at the beginning of
the Fall every single year I've done
this now
three times this will be my fourth I'm
leaving in 30 days from today and uh I
we just it's a whole summer so you need
a car you need your dog we have a lot of
stuff and it's just the easiest way to
get everything there until I unless I
can afford to fly private which I cannot
this is that when um so by the way I do
the same thing I I spend my summers in
New York and my wife flies and me and my
dog Drive uh there you go I found
another I found another person who
touched this when will you be wealthy
enough to fly private you think when are
you gonna feel never do you know what it
costs let me tell you a story this is
probably 30 grand from LA to SF so this
is the thing I I we go to Nantucket so I
so that's like the I'm at like the polls
of the country San Diego is the extreme
Southwest Nantucket is basically the
extreme Northeast so
um
I generally fly first class now that is
one of the splurges that I do and so a
first class ticket across country is a
thousand bucks or whatever and I'm like
thousand bucks this is great and I
thought to myself I'm flying first class
for a thousand bucks I bet I can fly
private for like you know three four
thousand I bet that's what it costs this
was me of of of uh naive Doug thinking
hey it's probably only a few grand more
you know what how much more could it be
and the answer is I looked it up 55 000
direct from San Diego to Nantucket and
so the answer to your question when will
I be able to fly private never my dog
and I will always pile into the car and
end up refueling at these sketchy gas
stations in New Mexico and Oklahoma that
will be our lives for years
how often are are people uh recognizing
you on these road trips at gas stations
all the time I imagine no it's rare on
the trips
um and I'm and I'm like I'm like
obsessive about getting there quickly
like I just go I don't ever stop and
like look at people or chat but in life
like yeah all the time obviously and
it's always nice it's always good
interactions with people well dude this
is awesome we appreciate it oh man you
want to shout anything out where people
should find you or where to reach you or
whatever cars and beds no we've talked
about every people can people will
figure it out well dude thanks for doing
this man uh yeah we'll we'll uh we'll
pimp out your Twitter the YouTube
channel cars and bids and uh you're the
best man I've been a fan for years it's
awesome to finally talk I appreciate it
thank you for having me and congrats on
the all the success um even though
you've been at it for you know I've
never seen Sam like this he is just
funny he can't stop he's just like
listen man if you want a carpool
cross-country sometime I I love our dogs
can sit in the back we can sit in the
front it'll be amazing
yeah you need a friend I got a friend
I'll be your friend if you need one glad
to have you on the pond glad they were
friends now right would that be fair to
say would that be a reach would that be
okay
I'm legitimately I'm thrilled to find
someone else who does this drive and we
should be in contact about that at the
very least I have become like a student
contact day yeah yeah we can start there
I'm happy to start there we could do
that
the funniest thing by the way Doug we
just did a live show in Austin and like
Sam is Sam is like the opposite of this
when someone's a big fan of Sam they
know everything about him they've been a
fan for years been following them
they've kind of falling over them huge
turn off to Sam but when it's somebody
that he does the exact same thing to
other people this is hilarious to me you
know I had this I had this happen to me
I met Jerry Seinfeld like a year ago and
Jerry tells me that he watches all my
videos and over at this point I've had
people coming up to me on the street for
years like I've had some of the
interactions you know great some of them
don't and I know exactly what to say
what to what I'm expecting someone to
say to have it go great you know and I
meet Jared he's like I watch all your
videos and I'm like uh uh uh
do you like Porsches
like I can't believe I've screwed this
up after having so much
okay well and by the way I know we keep
like we tried wrapping this up and then
we kept going so like I just really
acknowledge that because I actually do
kind of want to hear about this Jay Leno
I don't know if you know about this Sean
but Jaylen I was like car guy yeah
doesn't he have like four or five
airplane hangers is that what was that
like oh it's I've been there now three
or four times it is incredible
um yeah he's got like four one of them
might be an airplane hangar but it's
mostly just like buildings it's like in
an office Park it's next to an airport
but they're if they're not um but anyway
they're giant buildings yeah I would say
maybe six of them one is just like a
machine shop
it's incredible I mean his collection is
truly unbelievable
oh yeah
hundreds of millions you think so well
he's got a McLaren F1 that in itself is
probably worth 40.
um maybe 50 at this point a McLaren F1
is worth 40 or 50 million now wow yeah
that's pretty crazy yeah
at his he's it's like his is like a one
owner car is that a 25 years he told me
he paid 800 for it or six seven hundred
that's insane to me yeah yeah the car
Elon had that he crashed have you seen
uh Sean do you know what WeatherTech is
it's like uh it's like you buy a car and
you like get like the mats which is like
one of those businesses like Yeti where
you're like there's no way a cooler
company is going to be big it turns out
this thing's just massive and the reason
you know it's massive is I think it's
privately owned but they sponsor all the
stuff which you have to have a big
budget for but the owner bought a
Ferrari 250 GTO yep for 80 million
dollars which is like I think the most
expensive car sale ever yep and that's
how you know this company is killing it
that the owner of the privately Health
company has enough cash to spend on an
80 million dollar car that's just gonna
sit you know it's it's ridiculous I mean
it's like a crazy thing and so Jay has
one that's worth 40 or 50. that's got to
be in the top 10 of like most valuable
cars oh yeah yeah for sure and by far
the most valuable like modern car and um
he told me the most unbelievable story
about this car that he bought it he paid
600 and he told me he's driving through
La there's only 64 of them he's driving
through LA and um he sees another was he
driving it this was when he had bought
and he's driving through LA and he sees
another one so this is 97.98 this is
another one just Street parked in front
of a house and he's like
what and so he goes up and rings the
doorbell and meets the guy and he says
hi to the guy and they exchange rate oh
yeah we both got McLaren f1s in L.A and
he told me that the guy calls him a year
later and says Jay you'll never believe
it I sold mine and I made I got eight
hundred thousand dollars I made 200
Grand and Jay's like I think I'm gonna
hang on to mine a little longer and now
it's worth 40. and that's a lesson who
who's gonna buy a 40 million dollar car
I mean how many people in the world do
you think would do that are there any
emails in people I reviewed Jay's and
and I asked him and I had to cut this
out of the video because it was quite an
interesting segment but like I asked him
I was like what do you think of the
other owners of this car and he thought
for a long time and gave a very measured
response and I thought to myself like
what reading between the lines what he
was trying to say is there are a bunch
of jerks who have money they're not car
enthusiasts like if that car has become
the type of thing you buy if you just
want like a trophy rather than
if you actually care about cars whereas
when it was 600 800 Grand there were
enough car people who could afford it
that maybe they'd get into the mechanics
and do the work themselves which Jay
values very heavily but now it's just a
bunch of Rich guys who want to brag and
that's why he doesn't uh own Ferrari
because in order to buy the fancy
Ferrari you have to buy a entry-level
Ferrari and you get on a wait list and
they like release them like like a Rolex
almost and he's like nah [__] that even
though I'm a rich guy I'm I'm a man of
the people I'm not getting on a waitlist
to buy a a million dollar car there's
got to be 75 cars in that maybe 100 cars
in that collection and not one for our
that's insane how many people can afford
a 40 million dollar F1 or a McLaren
nobody and the ones who can servicing it
is a nightmare it's done on some like
MS-DOS based I mean the whole thing is
like a total mess it's but it's the
coolest thing in the world you know and
if you're a rich guy and you have all
the rich guy cars like the career GT and
the F40
you're not a really rich guy unless
you've got a McLaren F1 then you then
you don't even need the other cards
you're just like yeah I win don't keep
your how much is your monthly insurance
for a million dollar Porsche not as much
as you think I think it's only a
thousand a month to insure that car
um
but you can drive it do you drive on a
date uh like on a Friday night or once a
month I take it to Cars and Coffee once
a week basically but other than that
like my wife still hasn't even ridden in
it like it's just it's not something I'm
I I've driven at a thousand miles since
I bought it four months ago which is
actually pretty good but like it's a
terrifying thing to drive a car that's
worth a million dollars like anybody
could hit you and then it's like okay
well this is not gonna be good for
anybody like that person bankrupt now
because their insurance limit is way
below this and my insurer is going to
sue them and like the whole thing is
just it's just a scary
die I love driving I truly believe this
is the greatest thing you own that car
sounds like might be not so fun to own
that car no no I I when when I take it
out which is very rare but when I take
it out on early mornings before people
are up when it's still cool and I can
take it into the mountains and like
really enjoy it which I've done now
three or four times then it is so
rewarding and so incredible and I truly
truly believe that it is and I've driven
them all the greatest driving car that
has ever been made and so like to that
extent it's worth it for sure okay this
is actually the end of the podcast now
all right that's it Sam Sam you he's not
he's not gonna be your bestie he's not
gonna be your best friend yeah yeah give
it time bro give it time it takes time
we'll build a relationship I've already
got this planned out
there's gonna happen to be in your town
next week oh hey you're just in town
just I was hoping we could hang out here
for this
oh you're not in L.A you're in San Diego
tomorrow too
uh thanks Doug we appreciate it yeah
thanks guys
[Music]
foreign